let's have a look at this precise
example now just to pedal back one step
what I'm trying to illustrate here is
that even though when it comes to
differentiation we've got this this
general purpose question rule any
question you get handed you can
differentiate it but it turns out you
can't you can't just do that for
integration and the counter example I
gave you was if I took the same function
here x squared and we we did something
like this earlier this morning and if I
asked you to integrate this you're
pretty stark you're in some serious
trouble
at least with the techniques that we
have within the scope of that course
whereas this guy over here even though
it's not much different we can so let's
let's have a look at how to unpack this
particular example we will forget about
this one and we just have it got this
one okay now something you said before
was very prospectus perceptive right
which is that the numerator then you
find the numerator there it's it's very
close to the derivative of the
denominator that's a good thing if you
think back to do you have your reference
sheet somewhere nearby if you don't it's
okay because I'll pull one up I'm just
pointing that out because it'll help you
in a future like to be able to say okay
I don't need to remember all this stuff
it's it's given to me so the example I'm
looking for yes yeah yeah well it ends
up with a log so here it is on the UM
you see it there on the right hand side
right at the top there right so if
you've got this is I guess it looks like
a question yeah exactly so the
derivative of the of the bottom is the
top okay so we almost have something
like this so let's let's try and do that
okay I'm gonna peek back up over here
okay the first thing gonna do is as I'm
integrating the numerator the X and the
negative one I'm actually gonna treat
them as a completely separate so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna write x over
the left hand side 1x squared okay okay
and then I'm gonna take away one on x
squared like so it's that okay
hmm more or less right now the
derivative of x squared is 2x so I would
need to echo the table but in fact in
this case you can probably see if I pop
some brackets around here you can even
go one better than that because x over x
squared you can just do some canceling
right you've got a common factor on the
top of the bottom so in fact this really
is 1 over X at the front okay minus 1
over x squared with respect to X ok so 1
over X that's like the the most simple
version of f dash on F that you can
think of so what will the integral of
just that puppy the integral of 1 over X
that's gonna be its you can even see
here right it's just long yeah exactly
it's log of the absolute value of x yeah
it's a well you've got there's so many
different formulas you guys swimming
around your brain at the same time so
that's the first term so I'll in fact
what I'll do is just to make it a little
obvious so this guy turns into this one
so now when we haven't got this guy it
actually might have I should have done
this earlier but i should have rewritten
this in with a negative index so it's
actually minus X to the minus 2 because
this doesn't end up as a log I can think
about this guy just as a just as a
regular polynomial and do that thing
with increasing power divided by the new
power so help help me to do that what
I've got here is a minus sign that's
that's come from here now it's let me
just write that I'm sure right in
different color because no no this is
important right because this is what our
brain does all the time and it's really
dicey right you have you have seen
negative 2 and you're like 2 goes up to
3 right because you're increasing
integrals increase powers but by hew
differentiated because in fact because
in fact we want negative negative 2 plus
1 which is X
everyone exactly so and that's a very
very it's like we see it all the time
okay so that now this is correct so
let's make it the right color so it
takes to the negative one my new power I
need to divide by that so divide by one
and then I add my constant I just gave
you an indefinite integral
so therefore we have a constant
integration at this point I just need to
tidy up it's a bit of a garbled mess
right so got my natural log over here
yes so this this negative and this
negative figure cancel okay which is
great so I'll get plus X to the negative
one and my constant still there and then
I'm like well I introduced these
negative indices to make it easier to
integrate but I'm done with the
integration now so I'm gonna get rid of
those negative entities that I
introduced so that log is there and I'll
write that as 1 over oh you mean a
second derivative that kind of thing yep
so if I were to differentiate this and
firstly oh so that's it that's an
interesting question so let's just
suppose this guy in here this we call
the integrand right suppose well it's a
good question
would it be a hyperbola it would
certainly look like a hyperbola the
things you get when you divide one thing
by another they they share a lot of
qualities with what we call the
hyperbola so the shape you met back in
your 10 that looked like this yeah the
classic one right and actually as a
special ants called the rectangular
hyperbola for for long reasons that I
bother with you with right now actually
no what I will tell you I have purple
all right because we at some time our
hyperbola is special because of its
asymptotes right so it's got two
asymptotes in this case that the classic
one right and in this case the
asymptotes happen to be the axes as well
right
now what I want you to notice is these
axes are right angles because the axes
are at right angles okay now it turns
out that you can have other kinds of
hyperbola where the asymptotes are not
at right angles they may be like kind of
skewed in different ways like that so I
could draw a weird-looking one like I'll
destroy your one right now let's put
axes axes I could draw you one where one
looks like that
that's one asymptote and then I was
really going to draw the other
asymptotes like it this okay now you
could get this guy here this is another
kind of function okay it's still a kind
of hyperbola but I want you to notice
see this asymptotes right there no
longer perpendicular to each other yeah
that's right so this guy here it's off
yeah it's it's what we call oblique it's
offered a funny angle which means that
see this angle in here is no longer 90
degrees okay so therefore these guys up
here we call them rectangular hyperbola
because right angle that in Latin right
angle the word is just rekt angle like
that rect just means right that's why a
rectangle is a right angle Chang yeah
just brain exploded I knew there was
something worth going into that rabbit
hole so I literally on it anyway
all there just to say see this guy up
here the one we're actually interested
in
it'll have asymptotes and stuff but it
probably won't be this classic
rectangular hyperbola okay now you were
suggesting oh if this guy was a you know
a second derivative to integrated once
that tells us that this guy here would
be the first derivative okay because we
went from second derivative we've
integrated up to the first derivative
yeah you could start at whichever one
you want but the problem with going up
another step here it's because of this
guy here because of this constant right
so this constant
mock's about with things and it will
change what you get on the next step
right so that's why you know too if we
were asked to go further they would need
to provide us with extra information so
we could find out what that plus C is
actually equal to I mean you can but it
just gets Messier and Messier and
confusing and and you're like well I
don't really know what I have lots of
unknown constants just kind of flying
around so in reality when you get given
a situation like this they'll provide
more information so you can work out
what the plus C is and then if necessary
yeah yeah that's exactly right if I were
to integrate this guy you get log log X
however within the scope of the course
you don't need to integrate this so you
wouldn't have to worry about about that
guy but um yeah you could if you wanted
to dive down that rabbit hole so all of
that is really just a summary of saying
when you get you know you were saying
I'm having issues with integrating stuff
that looks like questions like this
right um
what might what I'll do is you can do
the same we'll look up some other
examples of this
generally speaking the key will be one
of the two things that we did here right
either it turns into a log of some kind
right or it's actually whoopsie-daisy
it's actually just um requiring some
algebra to show that doesn't turn into a
log at all you can see when we
integrated that right-hand guy it just
turned into it turned into this right
it's just um
based on this power here okay yeah you
have to play with the exponents asked
exactly right and sometimes you have to
separate it to like we did just in this
example to show how you can do that okay